Prisoners tell lies. Every corrections officer knows this. In fact there's even a joke about it.
How do you know when a prisoner is lying? When he opens his mouth.
I spent almost a year working as a state corrections officer or CO up at Sing Sing.
I wasn't there for the same reason as my fellow officers who were there for
a paycheck. I was there to learn about the life and be able to write a book about it. But
the inmates didn't know that and so they lied to me. The same as
anybody
else. For most of my time I worked in a place
called people B Block, it's a massive human warehouse with almost six hundred men in it.
One of those men was an artist, a Latino guy named Sunny. About twenty five years old
slightly built. He had a giant set of
Felt tip markers.
And for the price of four packs of cigarettes another inmate could pay him to do
a customized greeting card for any occasion. Easter - Mom
I miss you,
Whatever. But it would say the name of mom. And it would have anything else personal you wanted in it.
These things these works of art and they were, it took him two or three days
to complete and I'd watch him admiringly and he was a friendly
guy and I got talking to him and one day I said Sonny what are you doing in here?
I had him pegged for some drug offense you know some, some massive sentence
for a relatively small crime and he uh, he made a gun
out of his hand and he said, "Murder. Murder, C.O. - triple life".
And I thought whoa, you? murder?
About a month later
the department put an inmate look up page on their website
so you could enter a person's name, and it helps if you have their number too, which
I did. And when I did that for Sunny it came back "larceny".
So Sunny was a burgler, a thief, he wasn't a murderer, but he was in a place
where you want everybody to think you're as tough as you could possibly be.
And being a murderer is a good thing in Sing Sing. And I understood why Sunny
had told me that.
I had another inmate on the other side of that floor, was one of the very few white
guys on the floor. There are one hundred twelve inmates I
supervise four of them were white. He was one, he was a middle aged guy, glasses,
not much hair left, and constantly afraid of the other prisoners. You could just see him,
he's always looking over his shoulder - he was afraid. And maybe that's one reason he
was friendly to me.
And I liked him OK, and one day I said hey VanNess  so what brings you here anyway?
And he looked sort of ashamed, he said "Attempted murder, CO.
Attempted murder. I tried to kill my business partner." And I said "I'm
sorry to hear that"
And uh,
And I went home and I went home right away and I looked up VanNess
and he was in for second degree sodomy, which means sexual intercourse with somebody
under thirteen years of age. And you can see why somebody like that would be afraid
In prison. And you can see why somebody like that would tell a lie.
The most common I suppose was the one you hear almost every day which is just - I didn't do it, CO,
that's not me. I'm doing, I'm doing somebody else's time this is a bum rap, I was
framed. You hear this every single day and first I was kind of interested and I thought
wow a travesty has occurred and
I want to know more, but it doesn't take long you just filter
that out it. You just add it to the rest of the noise you deal with every day and uh...
And officers have a way, I have a response - they don't say this to the inmates, you don't want to stir things up, but,
the response we tell each other is yeah well. OK he didn't do that but you know he did something
else and, uh, it's
cynical. But you know most crimes go unsolved. And
when a person is sent to Sing Sing, when they are convicted of a crime, almost always
it's been more than one crime that got them there.
So it may be the officers are right, though that idea always
bothered me.
There was one inmate I talked to even though I didn't like
him. His name was Wari Al-Habib. He was an older man,
I'd say late fifty's, tall handsome. Wore a Kafia and other Muslim
garb and he loved to yell at the COs
He loved to get a good rant going and mine came one day when
I asked him for his ID card. And he had no reason to dislike me but, BING
ID card? You mean transit pass don't you CO? You mean transit pass
because this is South Africa. This is the apartheid system here. This is the
white man oppressing the black man. This is a bantu stand. You heard, CO? You know you know that word means? I bet you don't, do you.
Bantu stand CO, look it up.
And that's an unpleasant thing to hear. But
I was interested because the only
other explanation was the COs explanation of why there was this terrible
terrible racial imbalance in prison. And the COs explanation doesn't even bear repeating. So
so I was interested in what Habib had to say.
Problem is I couldn't tell him so. Because any CO who admits to accepting an idea like
that that, that the the system might be a little rigged, loses all credibility.
Not only among COs but among the prisoners.
They don't want to hear that from you, you are there to...To stand up for the law
and stand up for the system.
So I didn't say that to say to a Habib. But I did ask him other things. He got so much
respect from all these prisoners and I learned. One reason is he'd been in so
long. He had a bad a limp. He had a limp because he had a bullet in his butt
against his hip.
He had the bullet there according to him because the state wouldn't pay to take it out. The bullet had come from
a state trooper during the Attica uprising in 1974 I think.
And, uh, Habib
was respected for that. If he wanted
to shower and it wasn't his day for a shower the younger guys would say "Hey Conover give my shower to Habib, Habib can have my shower."
And I'd say OK. And one day I said to Habib
"Habib, what are you here for?" And he said "Oh man, I'm locked up,
I'm locked up for rape, man."
I said "What?"
And I believed..I thought...
First of all I thought he was telling me the truth but I couldn't understand all the respect he was getting if that was his crime,
because that's only
slightly higher on the scales and then VanNess' crime. So I was
intrigued by Habib. I was worried about him, but I was intrigued. I thought he
had a lot to
tell. And he left Sing Sing before I did. His arthritis got so bad he couldn't
climb the steps. There's a lot of steps there so he got sent to the geriatric unit
of another prison. Yes there are many geriatric units for prisoners
these days.
And when I quit. A few months later I thought, you know, all the
people. All the interesting people I met in prison who I really didn't have a chance to talk to,
Habib is at the top of my list, so I went back to that inmate look up page. Habib is now at Green Haven
correctional facility. I wrote him a
letter he wrote me back, and two weeks later I'm sitting in the visiting room
Of Green Haven. He's the only inmate I ever went to visit. And he is
so happy I'm there. Because I'm the first person who's visited him in more than
five
years. And. And I was happy too. I was happy.
because I thought for once, one of the walls is down. I'm not wearing a uniform.
He knows I'm interested in as a person. He's going to be candid with me. And the first thing I want to know
about this rape thing.
And it's the same rap I heard time after time at Sing Sing.
"I didn't do it Conover, it was a set up, I was...you know...
I'd been let out, I'd been paroled. I'd been free like two months and they're
looking for a con, they're looking for a time to lay this crime on.
And I was in my late fifty's when I got charged with that. I didn't do it. I got a good lawyer, though Conover. I got a good lawyer, she been trying to
get me out for years. She's going to get me out. I think it's going to happen real soon and
I said OK Habib,
you've got a good lawyer I'm glad for that. Tell me what else, tell me what else you went to prison for and he had
a long story. It started early on. He ran numbers in Newark, he
was called Newark Red. Then he told me became a gangster, "I was a stick up man
Conover". His
second. His second prison term was for robbery and assault.
And then he went in once for extortion.
He converted to Islam during his third term. He said it wasn't until then I
came down off my high horse Conover. I learned, you know, there's
more important things in the world than me and Islam had been good for him, you could see it filled his life
with purpose and discipline. And uh...
And I liked hearing about all that. And he was glad to tell it, and he was glad I was there too because of all
the vending machines around us. And in prison you
get kind of tired of the food and in the vending machines there's pies and sandwiches and
I bought a lot of those for us and
we spent a pleasant afternoon that
way. I couldn't figure out how to work Habib into my book.
He was such an interesting guy but,
you know, I didn't think he was telling me the whole story and I went on writing, I stopped thinking about him
until about four months later. It was a hot night in August.
I was lying on my bed. Almost midnight I was falling asleep I had New York One News on
and uh
The announcer said something about another inmate
exonerated on DNA evidence.
Barry Shekh today got another inmate free on the basis of D.N.A. evidence. And I sat up and I looked,
And damn if it wasn't Habib coming out of Green Haven prison
with his lawyer Ms. Peel and Barry Scheck. And I said "Oh my God" and I woke up my wife.
And I said "Margaret, you're not going to believe this, but
this is the guy. This is the guy who said he was innocent and he was innocent!"
And it shook
me up. I'm still shook up and uh...
I couldn't sleep well that night. First thing next morning I call the guy I worked with who is now an NYPD officer
and I said, "Terry, remember that guy Habib, he used to yell at us?" He said, "Oh yeah I remember."
I said, "Remember he said he was innocent?" And he said "Well,
I suppose,
everybody said that." and I said, uh,
"He was innocent. I just saw them on T.V. Barry Sheck just got him off."
And he said "That's interesting Conover. But you know if he didn't do that crime I bet
he did something else." And I thought oh man...
And
the problem. The problem that stuck with me was both that...in this occassion...maybe he did do something else
but he was doing time that wasn't his
To do. He did six years. He did six years that were, were not his crime.
The
second thing that got me was I was part of his punishment. I was the guy who locked him in every day. And that bothered
me.
I moved to New York about fifteen years ago from Colorado. And I thought you know to make it in a city
like this you're going to have to be a little more tough, going to be a little more suspicious, going to have
watch out for yourself, going to have to question what people say. Be a little
less trusting, don't take things at face value.
And especially, well, Habib taught me this lesson.
I mean. Let me step
back. Especially in a place like prison, you have to be skeptical.
Because you hear, you hear untruths all day long. But the lesson Habib taught me
was this - that if you don't question that reflex, if you
don't imagine now and then there's cotton in your ears and stop to listen to
somebody who is not listened to, you might just lose your ability to hear the truth when it comes
at you. So thanks. Thank you very
much.